many viewers tuned in to the Super Bowl
to watch the commercials in this morning
Amazon is getting high marks for this ad
Amazon's Alexa lost her voice this
morning talking like she lost her voice
how is that even possible we have the
replacements ready you just say the word
and you're sure this is gonna work yeah
not very convincing USA today's annual
ad meter found the commercial for
Amazon's Alexa digital assistant rated
highest it featured celebrities like
cardi B stepping in when she lost her
voice but at least one commercial
appears to have misfired Ram trucks is
being criticized for using the voice of
dr. Martin Luther King jr. in its
commercial the ad was intended to
highlight the value of service on the
50th anniversary of a famous sermon by
dr. King if you want to be
who is greatest among you shall be your
servant
Rams Twitter feed posted a statement
saying it worked closely with dr. King's
estate the official licensure of King's
speeches says quote we found the overall
message of the ad embodied dr. King's
philosophy the true greatness is
achieved by serving others I go ahead
yeah I really liked it actually I said
but we're thinking the same thing
because I was actually touched when I
was watching it the same with the
MassMutual ad where they used a song
I'll stand by you where they showed
people coming together in different
disasters I like those kind of things
I'd say once dr. King's words started
playing though I lost all contract with
whatever was being sold I mean they're
so powerful yeah I watched it with kids
and I said guys let's listen and they at
the end they said wow that was really
powerful it's nice to always nice to
hear his voice I think so too
always a news message did you have a
favorite oh I liked the Toyota ad you
know where they showed people who have
physical disabilities who go on to do
great things I thought that was great
first responders theirs arises yeah what
was that MassMutual I love it I'll stand
by you